joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line right now because we had josh
allen on yesterday's show we got to be
fair and balanced so we're going to get
one of the best in the business for the
tennessee titans joining us here on the
rich eisen show is perennial pro bowler
and yes mvp candidate he is derek henry
of the tennessee titans prior to monday
night football against the bills how are
you derek
i'm doing good how are you doing rick
i'm doing better for talking to you i'm
doing better um so uh after a sunday for
me um because derek you know not to bore
you with the details i wake up really
early and then i broadcast for four
hours and then i sit up my ass on the
couch and i watch football all day so
i'm well versed in talking about it
and then the next day i just you know i
getting up out of bed i kind of creak a
little bit but i'm also 52. what is it
like what is it like for you after a
football sunday your body
derek kennedy
uh yeah that that uh
after the game
after the next day the next day yeah um
getting up out of the bed
you know cracking
sore
and all those good things but right
after you know that next day the
recovery starts so i'm jumping on
recovery trying to get my body back on
me doing everything possible just so i
can you know get back
to my get back to feeling you know what
i need to feel to be ready for the next
game and you know feeling good during
the week what is recovery for you i
really would love to know what is
recovery everything from like
um cold tub
coat up hot tub
massage um dry nebulin
art
stretching
um
cryo
uh um
iv
um just everything possible that i can
do i try to do it uh epsom salt
everything epsom salt i like it okay
because the you know i mean every every
little bit counts i think you know where
i'm driving out here uh i i'm sure
you're aware you are on pace and this
isn't just because it's a 17
17 game regular season now uh derek
henry you're on pace to break larry
johnson's attempts record eric
dickerson's rushing yards record and
chris johnson's scrimmage yards record
you're being used a lot do you think
you're you're being used
uh to the way that just the way the game
goes or or do you think maybe things
need to be dialed back a bit even for
you
derek um is this
where the game's been going you know
what i'm saying and
you know
i pride myself on you know being the
leader and trying to make plays for this
team and you know this just being
available you know um my number's called
and just how to really how to how the
game's been going and you know
just
just that's just how it is but really
just taking care of your body and doing
the things you need to do just so you're
ready for the for the week after and you
know this is how things are
going right now which you know i mean we
just begin of the season this is still
early
but you know just how the game's been
going right now but just really focusing
on my body this time ready
are you worried nobody's ever had more
touches in the first five games of
regular season than you this year are
you or that
oh yes i'm very worried okay i mean
social media is keeps you aware of
everything nowadays okay and um so uh
and and the only person who's had more
rushes in the first five games of a
season was
uh oj in 1975 when he ran for uh a
million yards again you know it's just
so you feel like you're ready to go
you're ready to go when it comes against
the bills it'll just be another game and
30
carries or 35 touches so be it for you
that that's what it takes for us to win
that's what i got to do okay
and what does it feel like in the fourth
quarter when you're seeing people maybe
start making business decisions
for you oh on the other end i mean uh
usually you know if
usually you can feel us in the rhythm
and you know
the line of pushing forward and you know
re-finishing runs getting nothing south
and you know we gaining momentum and you
know just
playing our style of uh outstanding
football usually
ends up in the end zone but yeah it's
just us just you know sticking with it
and you know wanting to finish the game
with the ball in our hands and you know
finish the game with the momentum what
do you think of when you see somebody
who's a corner standing in front of you
and you're already throughout the gate
what do you think derek cameron can't
let him can't let him tackle you one on
one sometimes you know you get tackled
and guys go low because i'm a tall guy
which yes understandable guys try to
knife but you get one along the corner
you kind of don't want to
you know let them attack you especially
you want to watch right i mean but uh
what at what point do you employ the
stiff arm what's your process there
derek what's that one uh i can i can't
give all my secrets but you know it's a
uh there's a secret to the stiff arm
because it looks just brute force to me
it's funny it's only videos that you
know you can go from to kind of you know
get your answer no no no i'm just
kidding but it just depends on how they
approach me and you know you know just
watching film on you know feature
formula that we play and you know who
their dbs or backgrounds for who they
are
and just you know just try to time it
perfect and
use it as best as i can derek henry here
uh prior to monday night football
against the buffalo bills um to end week
six what about the bills as a measuring
stick for you and this season you're you
are the only team in your division above
500 you are three and two you could
start doubling up uh the number of
losses on your win column right now uh
what about the bills standing in front
of you and what they just did to the
chiefs
yeah tough tough matchup
very sound football team i think on all
three phases
um you know we know you know what they
have on offense you know they're
supposed to play josh alden playing out
of his mind right now i mean clicking on
all cylinders in the run game as well
you know receivers digs um knoxville
playing good and their defense i mean i
feel like they've been together for so
long that that chemistry is just so
strong and you know you see it in their
scheme they play so well together then
they added great pieces um you know this
this this year so even playing lights
out so it's gonna be a tough matchup
which is all it is when you play them
you know because they're a great team
got a great coach just to have a great
coach so it's gonna be a tough one and
what's it been like to be teammates with
julio jones i know he's been hurt but
what has he added to the team that you
hope to see
that veteran presence um god has a great
body of work guy that you know helps the
younger guys uh gives advice comes to
work tries to do whatever he can to get
back on the field you know going through
that right now and just doing whatever
he can you know don't help the team in
any way possible and you know that's why
i heard about him um and before i made
it to lee being alabama and then you
know you've seen him get to the league
and bring his teammate you know just
that's type of guy he is yeah so so he's
a veteran and he's a fellow crimson todd
member and he's kind of an og so you let
him choose what music's played in the
locker room right derek you let him do
that yeah yeah yeah yeah he he got it he
got it okay but is there anybody else
that you allow to do that or is it yours
i mean any other vest we got some uh got
a lot of vets in here so they won't
listen to that's what that's what
everybody wrote with
okay but otherwise it's yours that's
what i heard actually that you're really
in charge of that am i wrong i mean i
i don't really care i might have my own
headphones in but you know i'm usually
cool with what anybody plays i'm in my
zone anyway okay derek i'm going to use
the real estate that i have remaining
with you for something for me but it
really is something for you too derek
okay because i like you know i've known
you for a while i like you i really
appreciate your style of play and so
um you know you have a nickname right is
it king henry i see what you have on on
twitter
i think i think so i think i think they
might be my nickname
but i mean but people do they call you
king do you ask to be called king
derek uh no no no i don't have to be
called the king at all okay that's right
so i did i i did i made that twitter
handle my name um
in high school and that's just been what
it's been since since then and
you know
this is what it is well i got one for
you i've got i've got a nickname for you
and certainly since again as we
established earlier on that that that
people are concerned of the amount of
usage that you have
um and you're getting and that you know
running backs wind up showing
diminishing returns
and i don't think you're showing any
diminishing returns and that's not going
to happen as a matter of fact you are
the one who does the diminishing
you're the one who comes downhill and
does the diminishing so i have a
nickname for you you derek henry are the
diminisher
i love it
i love it whoa
should we love it okay so you understand
this is this means a lot to me because
i've tried
a lot
to give nicknames to people
in the nfl and they have rejected them
i've been
i love it i love i can tell you put
thought
and time into this nickname and i i i
definitely appreciate it like you said
we've been known each other for a long
time yes and i know that you put a lot
of thought into this and i'm very
appreciative it comes from the heart
this is
right in here you are the diminisher
you're the diminisher is coming to your
town to diminish
your
chance of winning you are the diminisher
in the fourth quarter the diminisher is
running downhill derrick henry yes right
but but you know what i gotta do what i
gotta live up to it that's the only
thing i live up to no you gave the
nickname now it's time to live up to it
i am not concerned about it that's all
i'm saying i appreciate it okay i am not
concerned about so let's print up the
her the the shirts and the hats and and
let's go i'm i'm and and you can have it
you take it how does that sound all
right you take it hey it's all good
derek henry finisher
say that one more time i want to hear it
say it one more time the diminisher yes
[Laughter]
derek you have no idea how much you made
you have no idea dad
oh boy literally i'm gonna stiff-arm
everybody else that's coming at me thank
you derek thank you derek henry you do
love it good let's see it let's see it
let's see it on the field i have no
doubt about it you take care you know
enjoy the cold tub hot tub whatever
you're doing and be well and we'll chat
again soon all right i appreciate it
thank you right back at you that's derek
henry the diminisher the diminisher
right here on the rich eisens show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here